à notre second thème tout de suite
pendant cette semaine on a décidé de
consacrer nos seconds débats aux défis
énergétiques demain on parlera des
éoliennes je dis les énergies du futur
et ce soir c'est la question de l'avenir
du nucléaire en France que l'on pose
peut-on s'en passer pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 avant de
poser la question à nos experts on
rappelle la stratégie et les projets
annoncés par Emmanuel Macron Sandra
serrequeira
c'était en février 2022 devant les
immenses turbines de général électrique
Emmanuel Macron promet de relancer la
filière nucléaire lui qui avait fermé la
centrale de Fessenheim un retour en
force de l'atome avec l'annonce de la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs je
souhaite que 6 EPR 2 soient construits
et que nous lançons les études sur la
construction de 8 EPR 2 additionnels 6
EPR construit sur des sites déjà
existants Penly Gravelines budget ou au
Tricastin
Emmanuel Macron veut aller vite un
projet de loi vise à simplifier les
procédures pour accélérer l'installation
de nouveaux réacteurs de type EPR 2
objectifs le début du premier chantier
en 2027 avant la fin du quinquennat pour
une mise en service à l'horizon 2035 à
condition évidemment de tenir les délais
contrairement aux chantiers de l'EPR de
Flamanville qui accuse plus de 10 ans de
retard et là d'ici là Emmanuel Macron
souhaite prolonger la durée de vie des
centrales existantes en tenant compte
des critères de sûreté si il est
nécessaire d'être prudent sur la
capacité à prolonger nos réacteurs je
souhaite qu'aucun réacteur nucléaire en
état de produire ne soit fermé à
l'avenir compte tenu de la hausse très
importante de nos besoins électriques
une relance de la filière nucléaire qui
doit aussi permettre de sauver EDF
lourdement endetté tout en soutenant le
développement des énergies renouvelables
notamment l'éolien en mer
face à ce volontarisme les ONG mettent
en garde la filière joue son va tout on
peut pas d'un coup de baguette magique
effacé des décennies de malfaçon et de
mauvaises pratiques dans certaines
usines cela va être un défi énorme on
peut le dire peut-être un surmontable
pour EDF d'arriver à la fois à assurer
une maintenance correcte de ces
installations prolonger leur durée de
vie et en plus
garantir la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs c'est difficilement faisable
ou alors c'est faisable en faisant des
impasses sur la sûreté sur la bonne
qualité des équipements lancez la
semaine dernière par le gouvernement une
concertation via une plateforme
participative en ligne prévue jusqu'au
31 décembre doit permettre au grand
public de s'exprimer sur l'avenir du
bouquet énergétique français avec le
nucléaire au cœur des débats
et je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Valérie fodon bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes délégué général de la société
française d'énergie nucléaire Gael
Giraud bonsoir vous êtes économiste
prêtre jésuite directeur de recherche au
CNRS directeur de problèmes de justice
environnementale à l'université de
Georgio aux États-Unis et votre livre
composé un monde en commun une théologie
politique de l'anthropocène c'est publié
au Seuil Stéphane piennois bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi sénateur LR du
Maine-et-Loire et membre du groupe
d'études énergie au Sénat laetitia
cruppa est resté à mes côtés
éditorialise politique peut-être la
question un peu générale qui est pour
poser un peu le débat et peut-être que
vous en pensez les uns et les autres la
France peut-elle se passer du nucléaire
pour atteindre les objectifs de
neutralité carbone de 2050 je commence
avec vous Valérie follon en effet deux
enjeux c'est un enjeu de sécurité
d'approvisionnement qui est revenu sur
le devant de la scène et puis un enjeu
de décarbonation alors ce qu'on sait
dans les scénarios qui ont été faits
pendant deux ans par tous les acteurs de
la filière y compris les ONG c'est que
pour atteindre nos objectifs en 2050 il
faudra consommer plus électricité
pourquoi parce qu'on va sortir du
fossile qui fait actuellement 60 % de
notre consommation énergétique le
pétrole et le gaz et on va électrifier
un certain nombre de process des process
industriels pour lesquels soit on va
électrifier directement produire de
l'hydrogène propre soit par exemple dans
le cas de la voiture passer à la voiture
électrique donc on va voir une
augmentation de la consommation
d'électricité donc la question qui se
pose c'est ce qu'on peut faire avec que
des renouvelables et en fait les
scénarios disent que avoir une part de
nucléaire un socle nucléaire parce que
le nucléaire est pilotable donc
fonctionne 24 heures sur 24 c'est des
scénarios à la fois moins risqués et
moins cher Gaëlle Giraud sont des
investissements très lourds dont on
parle qui engage la qui engage la
société c'est aussi pour ça que ce débat
il est il est très intéressant et ce qui
qu'il faut les maintenir est-ce que pour
vous le nucléaire c'est une obligation
d'une certaine façon d'humiliation pour
la société j'aurais aimé pouvoir vous
dire non et c'est ce que je vous aurais
répondu à 10 ans mais aujourd'hui à
cause du retard qu'on a pris dans le
développement et des investissements
pour les énergies renouvelables la
sécurité que je préside en mars dernier
a sorti un rapport sur un chemin de
décarbonation complet de l'économie
française d'ici 2050 et nous n'arrivons
plus à nous passer du nucléaire dans la
donc la réponse est non on en a besoin
et je suis entièrement d'accord avec ce
que vous avez dit à l'instant pour moi
le vrai débat c'est quel type de
nucléaire puisqu'on arrive plus à s'en
passer parce qu'on a pris beaucoup de
retard sur la transition écologique
est-ce que développer les EPR c'est la
bonne solution est-ce qu'il y a pas des
alternatives toujours à l'intérieur du
nucléaire beaucoup plus intéressantes
que le père pour faire la jonction en
quelque sorte le temps que le
renouvelable prenne le relais
depuis très longtemps y compris dans le
scénario nagawatt qui était de sortie du
nucléaire mais sorti progressive du
nucléaire aujourd'hui elle est tellement
progressive qu'on ne peut plus en sortir
d'ici 2050 à notre avis au sein d'un si
tu Rousseau il faut quand même diminuer
certainement la part nucléaire alors
engagé à faire en sorte que le mix
énergétique français pour l'électricité
soit 50% du nucléaire ce qui est
faisable sans changer grand chose d'ici
2035 mais si on veut garder ses 50% en
2035 il faut ouvrir des nouvelles
centrales d'où la proposition du
président Macron de lancer six nouveaux
EPR qui vont devenir opérationnel en
2035 la question que je pose moi c'est
est-ce que le père est la bonne solution
et la réponse est non
Stéphane piéma votre votre avis parce
que c'est en fait c'est la question de
on y reviendra un peu plus longuement
mais des investissements qui ont fait
qui ont été faits ou qui n'ont pas été
faits vous vous dites dans l'éolien
malheureusement ou dans les énergies on
le voit pour être beaucoup plus précis
ils n'ont pas été fait donc on est un
peu contraint de garder ou de réinvestir
dans le nucléaire vous vous dites quoi
plutôt il aurait fallu continuer
d'investir dans l'UPR exactement c'est
ce que j'allais vous dire dans ce
domaine là on le voit c'est un sujet qui
est au cœur de l'actualité avec la
guerre en Ukraine évidemment ça ça a
tendu les approvisionnements sur les
énergies fossiles et on se dit mais
comment comment on va faire on va pas
pas produire de l'électricité avec du
gaz parce que les robinets sont coupés
on est devant un mur d'approvisionnement
et on se rend compte subitement qu'on
n'a pas fait la transition énergétique
peut-être avec le développement de NR
mais surtout plus d'investissement dans
le nucléaire depuis les années 90 la
dernière le dernier chantier ouvert or
flamant ville le dernier chantier ouvert
c'est 91 pendant des décennies on a on a
rien fait on n'a pas construit de
réacteur nucléaire et je voudrais
rappeler à ce sujet là qu'il y a eu il y
a plusieurs technologies sur le
nucléaire il y a eu la technologie du
graphique gaz alors je suis moins
spécialiste que des que d'autres experts
mais néanmoins on a évolué ensuite sur
les les réacteurs à eau pressurisés
c'est le plan Messmer des années 70 et
le Pr n'était qu'une solution de
transition sur le nucléaire il faut bien
entendre ça
la transition vers des réacteurs qui ont
été imaginés au début des années 2000 et
pour les sur lesquels la France était
leader dans les années dans les années
70 avec le réacteur superfélix c'est les
réacteurs à neutrons rapides qui
permettent d'avoir trop rentrer dans le
détail technique parce que pour
une longueur plusieurs longueurs
d'avance et on avait du nucléaire
durable et on l'a sacrifié je voudrais
vous entendre sur le l'énergie nucléaire
et le climat est-ce que c'est une bonne
énergie pour le climat oui bien sûr
pourquoi c'est parce que ça a aimé très
peu de gaz à effet de serre en fait la
réaction de fiction de fission nucléaire
à la différence de la quand on brûle du
fossile ça émet beaucoup de carbone et
de CO2 dans l'air la fission nucléaire
n'aimait pas de CO2 par contre ça en
émet un petit peu dans la construction
de l'installation d'un fabrication du
combustible et puis dans le
démantèlement etc mais pour vous donner
une idée une centrale à charbon c'est
1000 g de CO2 par kWh une centrale à gaz
c'est 500 g
de CO2 par kilowatta et un éclair
français c'est 4 g donc vous voyez un
peu c'est c'est au même niveau que le
renouvelable en fait on va en sortir
absolument alors attendez
on va on va y revenir dans un instant
mais je vous ai posé la question est-ce
que Leclerc est bon pour le climat
volontairement parce qu'on est avec nous
alors malheureusement au téléphone on
devait être en visioconférence et puis
ça ne fonctionne pas le Duplex on est
avec hervécamp ce qui est rédacteur en
chef de reporter et le titre de votre
livre bonsoir La verset c'est le
nucléaire n'est pas bon pour le climat
qu'est-ce qui vous fait dire ça
je vais vous répondre clairement mais
d'abord
c'est avec trois personnes en plateau
qui sont favorables d'une manière ou
d'une autre nucléaire et que la personne
qui a un point de vue critique se trouve
au téléphone ce qui est désagréable pour
les téléspectatrices et les
téléspectateurs qui peuvent pas avoir
une égalité de de jugement et d'analyse
c'est pas notre fête on espérait que ce
soit un duplex et une visioconférence
mais je peux je peux entendre votre
argument allez-y donne le plus arguments
de fond et je constate le fait pour une
prochaine fois donc ce que j'ai entendu
depuis 5 minutes il y a on va dire des
choses inexactes tous les scénarios ne
disent pas qu'il faut du nucléaire le
scénario le plus sobre de RTE réseau
transport d'électricité et celui de
l'ADEME en au printemps dernier la dame
est une agence d'État
et le scénario de la dame est
extrêmement intéressant qu'il est
possible de faire sans énergie
renouvelables sans nucléaire pardon avec
des énergies renouvelables et beaucoup
d'économies d'énergie et que le scénario
où il y a et du nucléaire et du
renouvelable consomme demande en fait
beaucoup plus de renouvelable et coûte
beaucoup plus cher donc ça c'est un
premier point il faut remettre sur la
table le fait que le
l'économie d'énergie et le point central
de la politique énergétique et que le
nucléaire n'est pas forcément la bonne
option sur le plan économique comme sur
le plan de la sécurité deuxième point
j'ai entendu le nucléaire est sans
risque le nucléaire a d'énormes risques
et comme monsieur le sénateur comme
monsieur le sénateur l'a évoqué avec la
guerre en Ukraine on voit très bien avec
les menaces par exemple autour de la
centrale aux aboriggy que les centrales
nucléaires sont extrêmement vulnérables
deuxièmement il y a des risques
d'accidents qui restent notables ça a
été rappelé en janvier 2022
par le président de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire monsieur dorrosu qui a dit un
accident est toujours possible et ceux
qui en font le déni ne sont pas
responsables donc la question de la
sécurité nucléaire est toujours
extrêmement importante alors je vous
attends je vous interrompre parce que
comme ce n'est que du téléphone c'est
quand même effectivement assez
désagréable pour pour les
téléspectateurs Stéphane piénoir vous
êtes peut-être celui qui est le plus en
opposition avec les arguments
d'Hervé Kempf pourquoi vous nous dites
grosso modo on n'a pas le choix c'est
peut-être même le ce que dit avec elle
c'est derrière nous c'est dépassé
d'abord je voudrais dire monsieur les
pros à ceux qui ont fait du nucléaire
bashing on les a entendus quand même
très largement pendant des années et des
années depuis 97 j'évoquais l'arrêt du
réacteur super Phoenix c'est quand même
un accord politicien de Lionel Jospin
avec Dominique Vanet qui a sacrifié
toute une filière sur l'hôtel de cet
accord politique donc voilà pour l'écho
qui est donné aux anti-nucléaires moi je
suis pas pour un un mix à 100% du glaire
d'ailleurs personne ne revendique un mix
100% nucléaire pourquoi parce qu'on a
besoin de souplesse sur un réseau
électrique on a besoin de souplesse le
gros avantage de nucléaire comme
d'autres d'autres types de production
c'est qu'il est pilotable ce n'est pas
vrai pour toutes les énergies
renouvelables que sont les éolien et
d'autres et le photovoltaïque bien sûr
c'est ça le gros avantage aujourd'hui on
nous annonce 40% de de consommation de
besoins supplémentaires en électricité à
l'horizon 40% c'est pas c'est pas la
c'est pas la marge donc on voit bien
qu'on a besoin d'apporter de la source
et notre modèle il est fait sur de
l'injection
centralisée de la puissance centralisée
contrairement à d'autres pays qui
peuvent peut-être se s'orienter vers
d'autres types de production on a ce on
a ce modèle depuis les années 60 depuis
le général de Gaulle pour tout dire et
on a des faits des tricoté entièrement
ça donc je ne comprends pas en fait moi
je ne comprends pas cette cette
absolutisme en disant arrow sur le
nucléaire à tout prix parce que c'est
bien ça qu'il a qui a prévalu pendant
pendant des années des décennies je vous
donne un peu le gars Giraud merci
beaucoup moi je voudrais rebondir sur ce
que vous on vient d'entendre à l'instant
et en fait quand même donner raison et
avec M sur un certain nombre de sujet le
premier c'est le nucléaire avec le père
est effectivement dangereux puisqu'il y
a possibilité de fusion du cœur du
réacteur et ça c'est le risque Fukushima
et le risque Tchernobyl deuxièmement le
modèle EPR tel qu'on le envisage
aujourd'hui est un désastre commercial
est incapable de produire un
mégawattheure à moins de 110 euros le
mégawattheure on a plein d'alternatives
qui sont beaucoup moins cher
troisièmement il y a quand même la
question du retraitement des déchets
nucléaires qui est colossales dans le
cas par exemple des du système EPR et en
tout cas de toute réacteurs à fusion à
fission pardon avec
uranium plutonium donc à mon avis la
vraie réponse et c'est là que je suis
pas entièrement d'accord avec Hervé
c'est le point sur lequel j'ai un
désaccord avec lui j'entends bien qu'il
y a des scénarios avec une sobriété
énergétique drastique du type
franciscain qui permet d'évacuer la
question nucléaire c'est pas l'option
qu'on a prise avec l'Institut Rousseau
on a dit faisons moins d'économies
d'énergie en revanche
un petit peu nucléaire et d'option
nucléaire que nous proposons nous c'est
celle qui a été mise en avant par Alain
Grangent de carbone 4 et une physicienne
qui s'appelle Harley qui consiste à dire
remplaçant le père qui est un désastre à
tout point de vue par des petits
réacteurs à celles fondues modulaire
thorium c'est beaucoup moins polluant en
termes de déchets nucléaire pas
susceptible de d'être dévié à des fins
militaires on n'a pas on n'est pas
obligé de déployer l'armée française
tout le long de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement du combustible pour
l'empêcher d'être détourné par des
terroristes il n'y a pas de risque de
fusion et c'est beaucoup moins cher que
le père donc ça veut dire que l'option
prise par le prénom de la République et
le père deuxième génération n'est pas la
bonne pour vous valorifodon alors bien
sûr il y a énormément de technologie la
technologie selle fondue elle est
extrêmement prometteuse le problème
c'est qu'en fait elle n'est pas
disponible à l'échelle industrielle et
qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui de mettre en
confiance des réacteurs exactement
pourquoi on a besoin d'aller vite c'est
parce qu'en fait nos réacteurs ils ont
des plupart des directeurs ont commencé
à avoir 40 ans et donc on pense qu'on
pourra aller à 50 ans on pense qu'on
pourrait aller à 60 ans mais on n'est
pas du tout sûr d'aller au delà de 60
ans sauf qu'ils ont été construits très
vite donc à partir de la fin des années
2030 on a une sorte d'effet falaise
c'est à dire qu'il y a des années ça
paraît difficilement incroyable
aujourd'hui mais il y a des années on a
mis en route huit réacteurs nouveaux et
dans les années 80 donc en fait il
s'arrêtent tous en même temps
donc on a besoin de renouveler ce socle
nucléaire et aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait
faire alors c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
difficultés sur les directeurs européen
mais aujourd'hui on en a deux qui
fonctionnent en Chine on a celui de de
on a celui de Finlande qui est en train
de démarrer là il atteint les 100% de
puissance on a Flamanville l'année
prochaine on a deux en construction en
Angleterre donc on a une vraie
expérience industrielle et je dirais à
ce stade qui compte parce que des des
bas de clochers
ce qui compte surtout c'est d'avoir la
capacité industrielle de les construire
de manière efficace rapide etc et c'est
un acteur sur lesquels on a de
l'expérience et donc on pense qu'on peut
bâtir un contrat
un programme industriel
est-ce déjà trop tard pour relancer le
nucléaire on va répondre à cette
question ensemble je vous propose un
témoignage c'est ce que dit cet ancien
salarié des chantiers navals de
Cherbourg où se construisait les
sous-marins nucléaires français Yannick
Rousselet il est aujourd'hui militant
l'écoute encore récemment on a été
chercher des retraités qui étaient
maintenant chez eux tranquillement pour
dire bah écoutez là on a un problème
technique pour faire au fait c'était une
méthode de percement de la coque du
soldat sous-marin et on a été le
rechercher pour lui dire mais on pourra
te faire un CDD pour que tu viennes nous
expliquer comment on faisait à l'époque
parce qu'on ne sait plus et on a
complètement perdu cette capacité
industrielle et la retrouver ça se peut
pas se faire en quelques jours en
quelques mois c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement long extrêmement
complexe c'est pas de la formation
simplement qu'il faut c'est de
l'expérience c'est-à-dire des gens qui
vont faire des ratés des gens qui vont
faire après des réussites mais pour cela
il va falloir des années donc cette
question de reconstruire un parc
nucléaire aujourd'hui et là je suis
juste à connaissance extrait de du
documentaire nucléaire les défis de la
relance signée Marion Vigreux et avoir
en replay sur Public Sénat
pour une fois c'est que c'est vrai que
quand on construit pas on perd les
compétences on perd les gens ils partent
où il passe à Lyon
la chance qu'on a c'est qu'on vient de
construire justement on vient de
construire le réacteur de flamand vive
sur lesquels on s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait perdu en compétences et donc
l'idée c'est vraiment de construire de
manière continue voyez le programme de 6
il est cadencé en fait c'est-à-dire que
il y en a deux sur un même si 18 mois
entre les deux depuis quatre ans etc si
je dis de construire sur 20 ans de
manière cadencée pour maintenir la
compétence pour investir former les gens
et qui justement ils acquiertent de
l'expérience et c'est ça qu'on a eu dans
les années 70 et c'est ça qui nous a
manqué sur le chantier de flamande sur
cette question est-ce qu'il nous manque
une génération finalement de de
techniciens d'ingénieur de compétences
quoi alors non elle manque pas puisqu'on
a des on a des d'excellents chercheurs
physiciens et ingénieur au CEA par
exemple qui travaille sur la nucléaire
mais moi je voudrais répondre à la votre
objection qui est on a besoin de ces
centrales en 2035 c'est vrai mais le
père ne fonctionnera pas avant 2035 en
fait le thorium n'est pas plus lent que
le Pr si on lance aujourd'hui un plan
d'investissement sur le thorium on a du
torium dans 15 ans qui fonctionne à la
chaîne industrielle c'est ce que
m'explique mes collègues du CE1 donc en
fait c'est pas toujours très très
optimistes sur les dames
on est aussi très optimiste sur le père
ça fait 10 qui fonctionne dans le monde
aujourd'hui
mais on sait si justement c'est assez
représentatif c'est à dire qu'on attend
depuis 10 ans le père de Flamanville qui
est une technologie qu'on connaît donc
imaginez en fait
j'aurais vraiment hyper heureuse il y
avait du thorium en 2035 vraiment on
choisit ce qu'on le souhaite tous la
question c'est ce qu'on est capable
est-ce qu'on est prêt à parier notre
sécurité d'après énergétique et aussi
nos objectifs climatiques sur le torium
et en fait c'est compliqué aujourd'hui
on a besoin de sécuriser plus avancé sur
la technique
pourquoi c'est parce que qu'en fait si
on n'a pas la technologie à ce moment-là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait bah on va ouvrir
des centrales à gaz et on revient en
arrière sur les centres
à la fois le coup et les délais on fait
un focus certains font un focus pour ne
pas dire une fixation sur flamant ville
en relatant mais il y a de quoi mais on
oublie ce qui s'est passé à l'origine de
la filière nos réacteurs j'ai parlé de
la filière désolé d'empreinte un petit
peu dans la technique mais c'est
important de comprendre la filière des
reps ce qui la majorité de notre parc
aujourd'hui
l'un des premiers acteurs on a mis 16
ans à le construire un rector de chaux
on a mis 16 ans à le construire c'est à
peu près le même délai si on avait
abandonné il fallait pas nous promettre
qu'il mettrait 8 ans et qui fait c'est
pas 20 fois moins que le prix final tous
les gouvernements y compris les
ingénieurs y compris les chercheurs ont
été sont très optimistes mais si on
avait abandonné sur à l'aune de cette
mauvaise expérience de choses on arrête
on ne construit plus de réacteur
nucléaire et on en aurait plus dans
notre pays c'est exactement ce qui se
passe sur sur le LEPR de Flamanville moi
je veux croire l'une des horreurs de du
pays c'est de ne pas avoir construit une
paire de pairs parce que là on bénéficie
d'expérience de construction sur le
premier et on en profite sur le deuxième
ça ça a été un mauvais choix à l'origine
de pas de pas construire par terre mais
je suis convaincu que le Pr fonctionnera
il est prêt à fonctionner en 2023
probablement certes ira retard il y a un
surcoût mais de la même façon il y avait
des grosses surcos sur les rats il va
fonctionner ou pas
allez je me retourne de nouveau vers
Hervé Kempf est-ce que le les
difficultés je vais appeler ce terme-là
de Flamanville pour vous ça ça
disqualifie d'une certaine façon la
filière est-ce que vous allez jusque là
oui et je vais je suis désolé de le
redire mais je suis très profondément
choquée il y a quatre personnes sur le
plateau et les trois personnes pour
mettre en cause la méthode à chaque fois
je vais je vais arrêter de vous donner
la parole vous savez
Thomas je souligne simplement et je
pense que l'été votre avis sur la ville
c'est quand même problématique surtout
que des choses sont dites sont fausses
par exemple
le père de Finlande pour l'instant et de
nouveau à l'arrêt n'est pas en
fonctionnement il n'est pas à 100% de sa
puissance il a des problèmes techniques
les EPR c'est un processus qui avait été
lancé il y a très longtemps en
coopération avec l'Allemagne il n'était
pas question à l'époque dans lancé deux
puisque c'était une décision commune
entre deux gouvernements trois le
surgénérateur qui a été évoqué par
Monsieur piénoir a été un échec avec
Super Phénix a été un échec qui a eu
beaucoup de problèmes techniques et il a
été arrêté pour des raisons techniques
parce qu'il y avait une très forte
opposition citoyenne effectivement un
accord politique et le fait qu'il est
désaccord politique n'est pas en soi un
problème dans une démocratie
deuxième point les problèmes du
nucléaire en France sont aussi liés au
début des années 2000 avec les choix
néolibéraux qui avaient été fait à
l'époque et par exemple la politique
d'investissement de EDF qui était
extrêmement hasardeuse et qui a par
exemple dépensé des milliards pour
acheter une firme aux États-Unis
constellation énergie ça s'est révélé
une faillite
epef a dépenser des milliards pour
acheter British énergie c'était un
investissement tellement énorme que le
directeur financier de EDF a quitté donc
voilà beaucoup de choses inexactes sont
dites et il faut rappeler que finalement
si on a ces problèmes de nucléaire à
l'heure actuelle c'est aussi parce qu'il
y a une impéricie une
inefficacité un manque de rationalité de
jugeote de la part des gouvernants et de
la filière nucléariste et maintenant un
dernier mot je suis désolé d'être au
téléphone et Thomas Hugues j'en suis
désolé je comprends bien mais il faut au
moins je suis préoccupé comme les
écologistes par la question du climat
nous avons signé la France avec nos
alliés européens un engagement de
réduire les émissions de 55% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 c'est-à-dire il faut agir
maintenant et là j'entends les
discussions sur le torium et thorium
c'est en 2050 au mieux les autres c'est
pas fabriquer les deux paires de j'en
suis désolé ça sera éventuellement en
2040 nous on a une
trio climat et c'est
d'agir qui est important et je finis
là-dessus excusez-moi de prendre du
temps et je sais que c'est désagréable
au téléphone je m'en excuse auprès de
tout le monde
c'est des économies d'énergie qu'il faut
faire et ben pourquoi pas de manière
franciscaine cher Gaël Giraud
franciscain pour le rappeler c'était le
saint Françoise c'était l'homme qui
aimait les oiseaux et qui est
effectivement avait fait vos de pauvreté
mais peut-être que la société actuelle
est trop riche et il faut qu'elle
réfléchissent à être effectivement un
peu plus tard dans le confinement parce
que pour on a vu les effets du
confinement effectivement donc c'est
revenir au confinement c'est ce que vous
nous proposez
[Musique]
choisi collectivement et oui
effectivement
on a plus d'interaction sociale on a des
caricatures
Bolloré monsieur Bolloré Monsieur Arnaud
n'ont plus d'interaction avec des jets
privés parce que on rentre aussi dans
une logique de justice
qu'on a déjà fait sur ce plateau merci
beaucoup de votre participation hervécm
je vais vous rendre votre liberté à
bientôt on vous invitera sur ce plateau
j'en prends l'engagement je voudrais
faire un comment c'est que c'est tout à
fait normal quand on est sur un grand
projet d'avoir des problèmes techniques
et le rôle des ingénieurs c'est de te
répondre à ces problèmes techniques et
de les gérer et de la même façon ça se
passe sur le nucléaire que ça se passe
sur le parc éolien offshore ils ont
aussi énormément de retard pourquoi
c'est parce qu'on fait les parcs of pour
la première fois voilà et plus on en
fera plus on en fera régulièrement mieux
on le fera c'est comme tout voilà et le
problème c'est qu'on a arrêté de
construire nos remettons un programme
industriel en place
et je le redis ce débat il est
passionnant parce que les choix
politiques et on l'entend même quand
vous parlez technique en fait quel type
de nucléaire il nous engage pour des
décennies je le rappelle je vous propose
d'écouter un témoignage celui de
l'ancien patron d'EDF Jean-Bernard Lévy
c'était lors de la rencontre des
entrepreneurs de France au MEDEF on est
à la fin du mois d'août il revient sur
le manque de bras le manque d'équipe et
il fait le lien avec des choix
politiques
on manque de bras on manque de bras
parce qu'on n'a pas assez d'équipe
formée et on sait que notamment un
soudeur un tuyauteur il faut deux ou
trois ans pour les former et pourquoi on
n'a pas assez d'équipe formée et ben
parce qu'on nous a dit non votre parc
nucléaire il va décliner s'il vous plaît
préparez-vous à fermer des centrales en
un d'ailleurs déjà fermé les deux
premières on nous a dit d'ailleurs ce
sont encore les textes en vigueur au
moment où on se parle on nous a dit
préparez-vous à fermer les 12 suivantes
alors nous évidemment avec la filière on
s'est dit bah on fait quoi bah
évidemment on n'a pas embauché des gens
pour en construire nous on a embauché
des gens pour enfermer
et ça pose la question de la fermeture
ou combien ça vous dit du site de
Fessenheim Quentin calmé vous pouvez
nous nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
Fessenheim qui a définitivement fermé
ses portes en juin 2020 évidemment le
processus il est beaucoup plus ancien
oui ce qu'on comprend c'est qui a deux
contextes deux époques très différentes
qui s'entrechoquent autour de la
décision de fermer Fessenheim au tout
début des années 2010 la pression des
associations et les habitants de la
région est très forte en faveur de la
fermeture de Fessenheim c'était déjà la
plus vieille centrale de France ouverte
en 1977 alors que la durée de vie d'une
centrale une centrale est initialement
prévue pour 40 ans on a retrouvé ses
archives d'octobre 2011 des militants
écologistes déploie le signe nucléaire
sur le parvis de la cathédrale de
Strasbourg il y a aussi des élus de la
Ville de Strasbourg qui sont dans cette
mobilisation il faut le dire à ce
moment-là on est six mois après
l'accident de fukusima au Japon le sujet
va être comme ça au cœur de la campagne
présidentielle qui s'ouvre à ce moment
et alors à l'automne 2011 la gauche
trouve justement un accord pour une
majorité parlementaire en vue de 2012
alors vous parliez de Jospin voilet là
c'est en l'occurrence plutôt voilà
Martino Brie et qui reçoit au siège de
Solférino sur le nucléaire le PS et les
Verts actes notamment la réduction de la
part de la production de nucléaire dans
le mix énergétique de 75 à 50 % pour
2025 et la fermeture de 24 réacteurs
d'ici 2025 sur un total de 58 dont
l'arrêt immédiat de Fessenheim fait
partie de l'accord signé ce jour-là un
Solférino et une fois élu François
Hollande lance une grande conférence
environnementale il n'oublie pas la
centrale alsacienne dans son discours
écoutez ça date de septembre 2012 la
centrale de Fessenheim qui la plus
ancienne de notre parc
sera fermé à la fin de l'année 2016 dans
des conditions qui garantiront la
sécurité des approvisionnements de cette
région la reconversion du site et la
préservation de tous les emplois la
suite c'est un interminable feuilleton
avec voilà des reports tous les ans un
jeu de ping-pong entre les socialistes
et les écologistes ces derniers ont
régulièrement mis la pression sur
François Hollande afin d'accélérer le
calendrier de la fermeture d'ici la fin
du quinquennat mais en 2017 Fessenheim
n'est toujours pas officiellement fermée
malgré même un décret pris à la veille
de l'élection présidentielle mais qui
sera cassée par la justice et en
arrivant au pouvoir Emmanuel Macron
décide également de maintenir de
conserver cette promesse de faire mes
Fessenheim voilà il décide dans un
premier temps de conserver la
trajectoire de réduction de la part du
nucléaire dans notre mix électrique
français mais une évoque plus la date de
2025 mais donc il conserve l'idée de
réduire à 50% d'énergie nucléaire la
part dans l'énergie
électrique française écoutez Emmanuel
Macron né le 27 septembre 2018
concrètement 14 réacteurs de 900 MW
seront arrêtés d'ici à 2035
ce mouvement commencera à l'été 2020
avec l'arrêt définitif des deux
réacteurs de Fessenheim et donc c'est à
partir de l'hiver 2020 que l'on voit un
glissement s'opérer le nucléaire
redevient l'énergie du futur selon
l'exécutif notamment car son bilan
carbone est faible c'est ce que dit
l'exécutif à ce moment-là Emmanuel
Macron lance même un grand plan avec six
nouveaux réacteurs de deuxième
génération EPR 2 et il nous faut
reprendre le fil de la grande aventure
du nucléaire civil dit-il à Belfort en
février 2022 mais alors était-ce ne
teste pas une erreur que de fermer
Fessenheim quand on voit les tensions en
plus sur la production d'électricité et
voilà les dizaines de centrales fermées
pour cause de révision ou de risque de
corrosion la question elle a été posée
c'était à Isabelle borne le jour du
séminaire de rentrée c'était le 31 août
dernier écouter la réponse vous qui avez
mis en oeuvre la fermeture de Fessenheim
et souhaiter la réduction de la part du
nucléaire dans notre mix énergétique ne
vous sentez-vous pas responsable de la
situation dans lequel nous nous trouvons
il est où le sentiment ou pas avec le
recul d'avoir commis une erreur
alors vous savez c'est une forme de
paquebot une centrale nucléaire et quand
la décision a été prise dans le
quinquennat de François Hollande de
fermer Fessenheim cela veut dire que
la poursuite de l'activité n'était pas
possible dans ce quinquennat le problème
c'est que la première ministre ne disait
pas la même chose quand elle était
ministre de la transition écologique
écoutez c'était il y a deux ans vous
savez ça fait des années que on disait
il faut fermer des centrales nucléaires
il y a ceux qui en parle et puis il y a
ceux qui le font nous on le fait on le
fait ça n'est pas simple quand vous êtes
face aux salariés de la centrale quand
vous êtes face aux élus du territoire
vous voyez que évidemment ça pose
beaucoup de questions je pense que c'est
ce qu'il faut faire pour être moins
dépendant de l'énergie nucléaire et on
le fait vous voyez Thomas a beaucoup de
choses à dire sur Fessenheim ça a été
d'abord le symbole politique de l'accord
entre le PS et les verts puis un gage
Emmanuel Macron envoyé aux écologistes
la décision prise sous François Hollande
de fermer Fessenheim était sans doute
irréversible après l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron d'ailleurs l'avait dit dès 2015
qu'elle était tirée vers cible employant
ce mot en tout cas personne ne se bat
plus vraiment pour la défendre cette
fermeture dans le contexte de la guerre
en Ukraine et de la hausse des prix
merci Quentin pour toutes ces précisions
Stéphane piennois vous vous remontiez un
peu plus tôt c'est ça 97
à propos de Lionel Jospin alors c'est
c'est un peu facile à dire aujourd'hui
avec le contexte international mais
c'est vrai quand on est six mois après
Fukushima on peut comprendre aussi le
mouvement de l'opinion qui est pas
seulement français qui a un mouvement
mondial qui remet en cause le nucléaire
j'aurais fait une petite une petite
parenthèse justement sur une légende
urbaine que je viens de prendre par
exemple sur la longévité des centrales
nucléaires une centrale nucléaire ça vit
40 ans c'est le principe de
qui qui sera inscrit à la construction
la centrale ça n'existe pas c'est c'est
des ingénieurs qui à l'origine dit on
construit des centrales pour au moins 40
ans on a 40 ans devant nous c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose bon enfin la
petite parenthèse pour dire le constat
la question de la sécurité et parce que
quand on fait de la politique on réagit
à l'opinion publique et
et s'il y a aujourd'hui tant de
personnes qui disent on est pour le
nucléaire c'est aussi parce qu'on est
dans un contexte de guerre en Ukraine
d'énergie certes tous les arguments à
l'époque on est six mois après Fukushima
on peut aussi comprendre la réaction de
la gauche
d'abord il faut il faut préciser qu'un
réacteur nucléaire ça n'explose pas
c'est pas une bombe atomique ça n'est
pas possible c'est pas le même c'est pas
le même réaction physique d'abord il
peut y avoir fusion évidemment et des
conséquences très graves je ne minimise
pas ça mais ce n'est pas une explosion
atomique c'est c'est pas Hiroshima
deuxièmement j'insiste sur 97 super
Phoenix moi je suis pas d'accord c'est
pas c'est pas pour des questions de
rentabilité ça fonctionnait bien sûr
qu'il y avait des défauts bien sûr qu'il
y avait des dysfonctionnements mais
c'était en phase d'être de règlement et
surtout on était en train de régler le
problème de l'approvisionnement et des
déchets c'est à dire cette nouvelle
série cette nouvelle génération de
réacteurs nucléaires consommaient
l’uranium appauvri qui sort aujourd'hui
des Red de nos réacteurs pour une
nouvelle pour une nouvelle tournée si je
puis dire de de dans la chaîne de dans
la chaîne de du réacteur et je 3 je
crois fondamentalement à la lucidité
excusez-moi mais des Verts à l'époque de
comprendre que justement c'était
l'avenir du nucléaire d'un nucléaire
durable et suffisamment propre pour se
dire c'est ça qui c'est ça qu'il faut
condamner tout de suite il faut mettre
fin à ce truc là parce qu'on va la voir
pour des décennies des décennies voilà
ce que je crois fondamentalement
le nucléaire c'est aussi dans la mémoire
collective évidemment même si je fais
pas l'amalgame nucléaire civile du car
militaire mais quand même quand on dit
nucléaire on a tous un moment en tête
les bombes d'Hiroshima ils Nagasaki qui
qui rentrent voilà qui qui imprime notre
notre rétine c'est ce que l'humanité a
fait son de pire dans sa capacité
autodestructrice donc est-ce qu'on peut
faire abstraction de cette notion là
quand on débat du nucléaire je crois pas
pour une raison tout à fait en fait
évidente qui est que une puissance
militaire comme la France qui est une
des premières puissances en termes
d'usage nucléaire militaire en fait ni
crédible comme puissance militaire que
aussi parce qu'elle dispose de la
technologie nucléaire civile donc ça
c'est un autre aspect du débat
complètement différent qui n'est plus
simplement le fait que le Pr est un des
As commercial que c'est dangereux à
cause de la fusion etc qui est si on a
plus nucléaire on perd aussi notre
crédibilité en tant que puissance
militaire donc ça je pense qu'il faut
l'entendre ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
faire de l'EPR mais je pense qu'il faut
entendre cette aspect là qui est que en
réalité dans la vraie vie le nucléaire
civil et le nucléaire militaire ne sont
pas séparables l'indépend de l'autre
d'accord allez-y
il y a eu plein de grandes puissances
qui ont la France d'ailleurs qui a eu la
bombe bien avant d'avoir le civil on a
des puissances dans le monde comme la
Corée du Nord qui a le militaire mais
qui n'a pas le civil et on a à contrario
plein de pays qui ont le civil et qu'on
parle militaire donc la question c'est
la crédibilité d'usage de cet arbre et
du maintien de la technologie de l'arme
nucléaires qui utilisent de l'uranium
extrêmement faiblement enrichi avec des
bombes bâches enfin je mais bon
j'entends parce que je pense tout à fait
d'accord avec vous que toute façon le
nucléaire évoque plein de Halo
symboliques il évoque à l'eau symbolique
du il évoque le halo symbolique de
l'autorité de l'État même de la
croissance alors maintenant on voit des
gens qui sont décroissant franchement
c'est à Jean-Marc Jean-Côme ici il est
décroissant il est pro nucléaire voilà
mais souvent on est quand on débat sur
nucléaire moi j'ai pas beaucoup sur
nucléaire on est face à des gens qui ont
une représentation du nucléaire par
rapport justement à des halos
symboliques très forts et mais en fait
qui n'ont pas forcément une bonne
connaissance de la technologie en
elle-même mais c'est vrai que dans les
on va rentrer en débat public puisque à
partir de jeudi il y a un débat sur les
fameux le programme de construction des
6 européens donc je pense que tous ces
sujets là vont être débattus et c'est
justement l'occasion de le faire mais
pour moi c'est surtout l'occasion pour
les gens d'apprendre des choses sur le
nucléaire la moitié était français ne
savent pas que le nucléaire ne met pas
de CO2 vous font très peu de CO2 j'aime
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas
différence entre énergie et
l'électricité donc on rentre dans des
débats extrêmement compliqués
les gens ont des problèmes avec les
ordres de grandeur en particulier sur le
stockage de l'énergie il pense que parce
que Elon Musk a fait une batterie en
Australie bah ça va résoudre les
problèmes de l'intermittence des
renouvelable etc donc je pense c'est
important que les gens dans ce débat et
puis en profite pour apprendre des
choses sur l'énergie et se renseigner
alors il y a une question peut-être
d'acceptabilité par la société c'est son
qu'on va ouvrir dans notre débat
maintenant et et j'ouvre un chapitre là
dedans générationnel Laetitia on va
parler de Greta Thunberg parce que c'est
une personnalité dans dans tous les
débats climatiques environnementaux qui
qui pèse dans l'opinion notamment dans
l'opinion de des jeunes générations et
alors il y a un événement qui fait
trembler les pros et les anti-nucléaires
depuis deux semaines c'est une interview
de Greta Thunberg à la télévision
allemande ici c'est passé Thomas que
l'activiste préféré des jeunes qui
continuent de sécher les cours le
vendredi et de manifester devant le
parlement suédois elle continue à chaque
vendredi sont sa démarche elle a osé
nuancer ses propos sur le nucléaire
c'était donc vous l'avez dit le 12
octobre sur la chaîne das hearts on
l'écoute
personnellement je pense que c'est une
très mauvaise idée de miser sur le
charbon tant que les centrales
nucléaires fonctionnent encore
très passionné
mais pour le climat les centrales
nucléaires seraient-elles un meilleur
choix du moins pour le moment ça dépend
si elles sont déjà en fonctionnement je
pense que ce serait une erreur de les
arrêter afin de se tourner vers le
charbon bon il en a pas fallu beaucoup
plus pour que les pronucléaires crient
victoire Greta tenberg a retourné sa
veste Greta Thunberg est venue dans
notre camp et alors hasard du calendrier
ou pas en Allemagne savent d'autant plus
déchaîner les foules que il y avait une
décision d'arrêter justement les trois
centrales nucléaires en décembre et
quelques jours après cette interview
Thomas l'échéance a été repoussée à
avril 2023 est-ce que Greta tanberg a
pesé dans cette décision ou pas on n'en
sait rien ces propos ils ont touché la
France aussi oui oui pas plus tard que
le lendemain on va écouter
la réaction de Marina Le Pen c'est donc
le 13 octobre à l'Assemblée nationale
elle est galvanisée
claire puisque j'ai lu cet après-midi
que leur gourou de 15 ans et demi vient
de dire que pour finir elle est pour le
nucléaire merci mademoiselle Thunberg
à noter que Créteil Berg a 19 ans et pas
15 ans et demi qu'elle n'est pas un
gourou mais une activiste une militante
et qu'elle est encore très très loin
d'être pro nucléaire alors justement on
va rentrer dans le détail pour vous
c'est une récupération politique de ces
propos qui était assez mesurés
totalement et puis elle a l'habitude un
Greta Tomberg à la tweeté ensuite pour
dénoncer cette instrumentalisation de
ses propos dans cette interview à la
télé allemande qu'est-ce qu'elle dit
elle dit juste que de façon pragmatique
elle préfère que le nucléaire qui est
déjà en marche continue plutôt que on
donne la valve centrale à charbon en
Allemagne mais elle ne donne pas du tout
son avis par exemple sur les centrales
après la crise énergétique et puis sur
la construction par exemple de nouveau
OPR d'ailleurs en juillet dernier elle
s'était opposée au label vert vous savez
que l'Europe avait donné notamment au
gaz et au nucléaire en disant que nous
avons désespérément besoin de vrais
énergies renouvelables j'accident pas de
solution fausse donc Greta Thunberg
reste vraiment très favorable aux
énergies renouvelables mais la question
elle sera forcément de nouveau posée oui
parce que en fait elle a sorti un livre
et elle est en tournée mondiale le livre
c'est le grand livre du climat elle a
dirigé ce livre il y a une centaine
d'auteurs donc on devrait pas avoir de
très grosses surprises on devrait avoir
cette question qui va se répéter mais la
force de Greta Thunberg c'est justement
qu'elle ne change pas sa ligne et
qu'elle scande ses messages depuis
maintenant 7 ans oui merci Laetitia pour
toutes ces précisions Gaël Giraud le
nucléaire c'est peut-être l'un des
héritages que cette génération nous
reproche de lui laisser est-ce que vous
l'analysez comme ça oui c'est vrai que
cette génération nous fait un procès de
lui laisser une terre qui est en feu qui
éventuellement pourra conduire à
l'extinction de l'humanité au siècle le
prochain ce qui devient un sujet
scientifique aujourd'hui malheureusement
criblé de dettes c'est dans un monde où
ils ont pas de travail ils n'ont pas
d'actif c'est la génération ninja
nowhincom no job no Watt voilà donc je
pense il faut que nous on prenne
conscience de ce procès qui nous est
fait par cette génération et qu'on
entend dialogue là-dessus qu'on se
justifie sur nos soins de société je
voudrais revenir un instant sur Greta
tunnel je crois effectivement que ce
qu'elle a dit était très fin et en fait
qui relève du bon sens les centrales
déjà existantes c'est idiot de les
fermer c'est pour les remplacer par les
centrales à charbon et je pense qu'avec
ça tout le monde est d'accord c'est pas
du tout un plaidoyer en faveur du
nucléaire il y a un autre personnage
dans l'autorité morale est incontestée
c'est le peuple le pape François a pris
position très explicitement contre le
nucléaire et j'ai moi-même été à ce
moment-là approché par le gouvernement
français qui me demandait parce qu'à ce
moment-là le président Macron voulait
proposer le nucléaire français à
l'Europe est-ce que vous pourriez pas
essayer d'approcher le pas pour lui
faire changer d'avis alors c'était une
trahison d'une méconnaissance craque de
la diplomatiematicale et une exagération
du pouvoir des Jésuites comme si les
Jésus pouvaient changer de l'opinion du
pape mais je crois que c'est un lieu de
discussion fort et Emmanuel Macron et
vient justement de rendre visite au pape
j'espère qu'ils ont eu l'occasion d'en
parler combien de milliards d'euros pour
relancer le nucléaire en France écoutez
ce qu'on dit Bernard dossouk est le
président de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire et les réclame un plan
Marshall je choisis volontairement cette
expression parce que dans l'esprit
général ça marque et le plan Marshall
dans l'esprit commun c'est à la fois un
plan de reconquête et un plan de
réindustrialisation et effectivement
pour pouvoir accompagner les projets de
nouveaux nucléaires pour pouvoir
accompagner les travaux importants pour
la poursuite d'exploitation des
centrales mais aussi des installations
du cycle combustible il faudra procéder
à des investissements massifs et il
faudra procéder à une reconquête
industrielle il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin ce n'est pas avec le plan de
relance tel qu'il est prévu avec les
efforts qui sont prévus par la filière
ils vont dans le bon sens mais ils ne
sont pas à dimension de ce qui est
nécessaire pour avoir à la fois un
programme qui soit robuste réaliste et
réalisable Stephen piennois vous êtes
d'accord avec avec cet appel est-ce que
finalement ce qui a été annoncé par
Emmanuel Macron et suffisant d'abord on
est resté au stade des annonces à ce
jour il y a toujours rien engagé on a
parlé des délais tout à l'heure on sait
que de toute façon une centrale
nucléaire un minima c'est 10 ans on peut
faire les annonces qu'on veut c'est 10
ans donc moi j'attends les annonces
vraiment plus que les annonces les
signatures de contrat on n'y est pas
encore on nous a dit vous savez qu'on a
un projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables qui venait en débat au
Sénat on nous a annoncé aussi un projet
équivalent sur le sur le nucléaire en
gros pour court-circuiter les enquêtes
publiques pour accélérer bon j'ai pas
l'impression que ça va ça va porter
beaucoup ses fruits en tout cas ce qui
nous manque et vous voulez très bien dit
c'est vous aussi c'est le pragmatisme
dans ce débat qui était souvent
passionné on le voit en hémicycle au
Sénat mais j'imagine aussi à l'Assemblée
nationale il faut du pragmatisme fermer
des centrales comme Fessenheim
d'ailleurs pour rouvrir des centrales à
charbon comme saint Paul ou dans mon
dans ma région à Cordemais on a
multiplié par trois la production
d'électricité on parle que d'électricité
produite charbon enfin c'est c'est
dramatique avec 1000 g de CO2 contre 6
alors sur le long des estimations 6 ou
12 pour le nucléaire enfin on voit on
voit que c'est c'est un non-sens total
et là où je suis d'accord avec Monsieur
Games tout à l'heure c'est que les
décisions qui ont été prises il y a 25
ans on est en train de les payer de les
payer très cher on est on est devant un
mur d'approvisionnement de déficit
d'approvisionnement parce qu'on n'a pas
pris les bonnes décisions il y a 25 ans
parce qu'on a continué à les alimenter
et à faire du nucléaire bashing comme je
disais tout à l'heure et là on a un gros
souci c'est que quoi qu'on dise on va
pas entrer on va pas c'est ça la société
des on va pas tous se vivre dans des
grottes dans demain matin on a besoin
d'énergie on a assez c'est le c'est le
l'essor du développement de toute
société et cette énergie cette
électricité on en a besoin tout de suite
mais on peut pas attendre qu'une même
qu'une centrale nucléaire se
construisent et même que des mêmes que
des éoliennes se montent sur terre ou en
mer
les énergies renouvelables oui enfin
c'est de l'ordre de 10 ans néanmoins et
c'est là on voit bien qu'on n'est pas
dans la dans la politique du court
thermiste en envoyant des chèques ça
marche je voudrais qu'on parle de
l'acceptabilité quand même pas par
l'opinion parce que il y a une grande
concertation qui est qui est lancée j'ai
entendu ça mais à côté de ça il y a une
loi qui est votée en disant on va
alléger les procédures administratives
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que on
n'aura pas de recours
en fait c'est oui c'est des vraiment des
procédures assez compliquées parce que
en fait besoin de 15 autorisations pour
une centrale nucléaire donc il y a une
sorte de chèvrement administratif donc
c'est surtout là-dessus le départ vous
l'avez dit mais est-ce que pour autant
il faut se passer de il faut aller j'ai
le droit mais non le débat il démarre
jeudi en fait il est sur le chemin il va
durer quatre mois jusqu'à fin février
donc le débat il est en train de
commencer c'est et après il va y avoir
un débat au Parlement donc on est
vraiment dans un process
légal de débat alors l'opinion publique
on a des données donc c'est vrai qu'il y
a une remontée assez forte du nucléaire
dans l'opinion publique et pour des
raisons qui sont des raisons de sécurité
d'approvisionnement électrique ce qu'on
ce qu'on n'a pas dit mais ce qui est
assez important c'est qu'on a fermé
énormément d'installations
touche les choix énergétiques encore
fois ne nous engage pour des décennies
est-ce qu'il a vraiment eu lieu non il a
pas eu lieu du tout pour l'instant
j'espère qu'il va avoir lieu je suis un
petit peu sceptique quand je vois le
débat qu'on a vu sur la convention
citoyenne pour le climat et la manière
dont on organise le débat dans cette
dans ce pays depuis quelques années mais
j'espère qu'il aura lieu sur le
nucléaire je crois qu'il y a quand même
deux points qui faut souligner le
premier c'est quand même le risque
Fukushima de fusion du cœur du réacteur
ça ce risque est majeur avec le père ne
risque zéro ça n'existe pas je veux dire
il faut quand même être capable
d'assumer un risque de cette nature si
un jour ça nous pète à la figure si je
puis dire et si les il a été conçu pour
diminuer le risque de
diminuerait sans rejeter
assument ceci puis troisièmement la
question des déchets nucléaires qui eux
sont restés radioactif pour des milliers
d'années qui font enfouir extrêmement
profondément et ça c'est un enjeu c'est
le leg qu'on laisse non pas pour la
génération future mais pour des milliers
de générations futures et qui ne sont
pas en contact avec la biosphère à la
différence du CO2 elles sont enfouies
sous terre qui ne peuvent jamais être
complètement séparés du de la de la de
notre planète
on aurait pu encore le prolonger ce qui
prouve que il y a beaucoup de évidemment
de thèmes à aborder c'était passionnant
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'y avoir
participé Gaël Giraud je rappelle le
titre de votre livre composé un monde en
commun une théologie politique de
l'anthropocène c'était édité aux
éditions du Seuil demain l'invité de la
matinale c'est Boris Vallot président du
groupe socialiste et apparenté à
l'Assemblée nationale face à Oriane
mansouni à 8h merci à toutes et à tous
bonne soirée merci
[Musique]